[music playing]
ALBERT LIN: I'm headed
to the lost city
of Chan Chan, once
the beating heart
of the mighty Chimu empire.
Is that a pyramid?
I think that's a pyramid.
A pyramid at Chan Chan.
Can I find the answers
inside the city walls
as to why the
children had to die?
Built over a thousand years
ago, amazingly much of the city
has survived.
And I've been told to expect
something spectacular.
Look at these walls.
They stretch as far
as the eye can see.
I got my drone up, taking
a closer look right now.
Looks like a labyrinth of walls.
I'm using photogrammetry
data with graphic modeling
to rebuild the city and
these extraordinary walls.
Here they are restored to
their full glory, a truly awe
inspiring sight rising
out of the desert
like something out of a fable.
At its dazzling peak
in the 15th century,
the city was a bustling
home to 60,000 people,
about the size of
London at the time,
and covering 14 square miles.
This is one of the greatest
cities of human history.
So why did it
collapse so suddenly?
I'm here to meet
Peruvian archaeologist,
Arturo Paredes Nunez, who's
been working here for years.
Ironically his last
name means wall.
[speaking spanish]
This is Chan Chan.
Look at all these carvings here.
It's-- it looks
like digital fish.
The Chimu covered the city
with carvings of the ocean.
Wow.
Look at these.
They're everywhere.
But among all these
artworks is one Arturo
really thinks I need to see.
An entire wall in
the central palace
is devoted to a giant
mural over 170 feet long.
Wow.
Look at this.
What is this?
ARTURO PAREDES NUNEZ:
[speaking spanish]
ALBERT LIN: Fish.
Yes.
[speaking spanish]
And each one of these
is actually a wave moving
down towards the coastline.
Are these currents?
[speaking spanish]
ALBERT LIN: All these fish,
they're going in a direction.
They're traveling
from south to north.
They're actually following
the course of a current,
the Peruvian current.
But a closer look reveals that
the mural also depicts a moment
of great change, another
current coming back
in the other direction, fish
swimming in the opposite way,
north to south.
Incredible.
Is this right?
Did I get this?
Did I get this right?
It looks like the Chimu are
recording a dramatic shift
in the ocean currents.
And when that happens, something
else dramatic happens, too.
A violent shift in the climate.
Were the Chimu recording
a huge natural disaster
on those walls?
Were they chiseling
a premonition
of their own destruction?
I need to check the data
to see if they were right.
This is a dry, arid desert.
But a sudden switch in
the Pacific Ocean current
can trigger violent change
and devastating rain.
Look at this.
Everything flips.
Because the ocean currents are
tied to the weather currents.
Everything's tied together.
I know this kind of thing.
I live on the Pacific coast
myself, just in North America.
This climate shift
is called an El Nino.
These days, it happens
about once every five years.
But once in a generation,
you get a really
big or long lasting event.
That's called a Super El Nino.
And the impact can
be catastrophic.
Wait a minute.
Look at this, the data right
here, this rainfall data.
Every year for the last decade,
less than half an inch of rain.
And then boom,
2017, one big spike,
four inches of rain
in a single year
completely out of the blue.
It happened as recently as
2017, destructive floods in Peru
caused by torrential rains
triggered by a severe El Nino.
Maybe there's clues in the
experiences in that El Nino
that'll tell me what might
have happened to the Chimu.
I'm gonna go try to
meet some people.
In 2017, the city of Trujillo,
just three miles from Chan Chan
and also sandwiched between
the sea and the mountains,
was one of the worst hit.
[dog barking]
I'm here to meet some people
who almost lost everything.
One local family
filmed the flood
as it tore through their home.
Never seen anything
like this before,
this much moving material,
water just rushing
down through the streets.
This whole thing would
have been a river.
You can actually see the
storm in the background.
[inaudible]
The more I talked to
people in Trujillo,
the more I hear this
word, [inaudible]..
It doesn't sound
like Spanish to me.
[inaudible] is Quechua or is--
Quechua.
It is?
Quechua is an ancient language
of Peru, predating the Spanish.
Wow, that's incredible.
This has happened so
many times for so long
that there's an ancient word.
It's something that's
embedded in the memory.
[inaudible]
[speaking spanish]
An avalanche.
This term, [inaudible],, is
used to describe a combination
of water, mud, stone, debris.
Coming not from the
ocean in the west,
but from the east in the
mountains behind the city.
Is it possible
that the same type
of event happened to the Chimu?
If it did, then there
must be some way
of finding evidence
that an El Nino
event happened in their time.
And the answers may be
up in those mountains.
[soft music]